more people living on american streets
at any time in a hundred years it's
getting very noticeable it's obviously a
sign of decay it's scary actually so joe
biden has finally named someone to be
his new homelessness czar
turns out the problem is we're all too
transphobic that's why we have the
homeless so biden has appointed an
aspiring musician called jeff olivette
jason rantz has been looking into mr
olivette jason rance is the host of the
jason ranch show on ktth you're always
happy to have him join us jason thanks
for coming on who is this guy
uh he is someone who is deeply
unimpressive and a long-established
member of the homeless industrial
complex he most recently became an
anti-racist consultant who tells white
people to curb their white privilege
which is ironic because he probably used
that to land this new job so of it
basically views homelessness through a
critical race theory and social justice
lens which basically means he blames
homelessness on racism because the
homeless population is
disproportionately black so what he's
basically saying is look if you're black
if you have a mental illness or an
addiction and you're homeless he says
it's because of institutional racism and
the health care system that didn't give
you affordable health care treatment to
begin with that led you to become
freaking serious are you serious that is
is there any end to these people will
they just stop breaking things
are you fairly characterizing this guy's
views because it's like how much more of
this can we take
yeah no i was in the same way i've been
looking over and over a lot of his
interviews and
it's pretty clear where he stands he's
basically saying look if you're going to
end racism you have to
get at the root causes and then that
turns into ending homelessness and he
actually explains what needs to happen
he says in this interview here with a
non-profit called family promise
if we don't
uh pull it out by the root if we don't
address the deep structural underlying
racism that is driving high rates of
homelessness uh for people of color and
families of color then there's no way
we'll ever end it
so that doesn't actually explain why
white people are homeless or asians or
latinos but it's not a priority for this
white house so moving forward this is
what we can expect he's going to pour
billions of dollars into a housing first
strategy which kind of functions the way
it sounds so the homeless get housed
first meaning there's no conditions on
the housing like getting addiction
treatment so you're not shooting up in
the subsidized home
and usually proponents will look to salt
lake city because they use this model
and it's been really effective in
getting like 95 of the homeless people
that they get into contact with into
housing however the studies show they
don't actually become self-sufficient so
that's in part because of the underlying
conditions that are never treated
successfully so using this approach
nationally basically means you're going
to be spending billions of dollars on
housing and case management where the
homeless never actually leave and so
your question which i think is a a
legitimate one is some like how did
someone like this get to this position
and maybe it has nothing to do with
homelessness maybe it's the other skills
maybe you can entertain the white house
interns but you know exactly
it's the same gig all the time you blame
whitey and then you take money from
developers so this is a payoff to
developers of course private equity is
buying up all the single-family homes so
we're gonna build a lot more
multi-family housing developers are
going to get rich all under the cover of
wokeness like we're on to the game now i
mean it's just totally it's clear as day
and we know exactly how much money
they're going to be putting into it it
is absolutely ludicrous and people
better step up because otherwise all
we're doing is creating a situation
where they never actually get out of the
homelessness right it doesn't help
anybody except the developers of course
jason rantz great to see you thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else